back to the breaking news we told you
about uh some moments ago british media
reporting that britain's prime minister
boris johnson has agreed to resign
he's faced a growing rebellion within
his ruling party over a series of
scandals more than 50 members of his own
government have resigned let's go live
to downing street al jazeera's paul
brennan uh is there paul what's the
latest
the latest is well the latest as far as
the total goes is 55 now members of the
government who've resigned i'll go back
through some of them at the moment but
the most important line that's just
emerged
in the last 15 20 minutes is a
communique from downey street which says
um the prime minister will make a
statement to the country today and the
understanding is that boris johnson uh
will step down uh as prime minister
today he will resign uh he wants to
continue as prime minister until the
autumn um that said uh but there will be
a leadership race for the conservative
party leadership
during the summer and um the intention
is that there will be a leader in place
of the conservative party before well by
the time of the conservative party
annual conference which takes place
in october
so a brief uh statement from downing
street saying the prime minister will
make a statement to the country today
what we expect to happen is that a
pedestal a plinth will come out from the
door behind me number 10 into the into
the street uh microphones will be
attached and at some point um boris
johnson will emerge having bowed frankly
to the inevitable after the pressure
that has been put on him uh to step down
both well for the good of the party for
the good of the country he was vowing to
hang on vowing to defy the critics
insisting that he had a mandate from the
14 million people that he said voted for
him um during in the 2019 election
despite the fact that his cabinet
ministers were putting in their
resignation letters and some of the
language that they were using in those
letters was utterly scathing of boris
johnson's leadership uh of his integrity
of his vanity as well
the most recent one to go was caroline
johnson who's the conservative party
chairman the cumulative effect of your
errors of judgment she wrote have
squandered the goodwill of our great
party and you know she's just one of
that's 50 she was the 55th member of the
government to quit he was frankly
running out of um staff running out of
uh people in government to to govern
with and paul just remind us how we got
to to this point what's led
to this political crisis
the the the straw that broke the camel's
back was an incident with a
member of the government whose job is
deputy chief whip now it's repo
responsible for party discipline
essentially a man called chris pincher
who uh was very very drunk in the
carlton club uh during the course of uh
last week uh and essentially sexually
assaulted uh a male staffer now
the boris johnson uh was questioned as
to how chris pincher had been appointed
to this job when given the fact that he
had a little bit of a track record uh
for this he had been had been an
incident when he was at the foreign
office back in 2019 uh and boris johnson
said he had no knowledge of any prior
situation about chris pinch or prior
concerns in fact he was called out uh
for that being untrue boris johnson had
been briefed in person
uh about the situation with chris
pincher and about the fact that chris
pincher's uh conduct had resulted in a
formal process and that the complaint
had been upheld boris johnson tried to
wriggle out of that by saying oh yes i i
forgot about that sorry yes uh i'm sorry
but um it was simply an oversight a a
misrecollection
uh but the
weary mps on his own party of the
conservative party frankly had had
enough because we've had a succession of
this we've had partygate for example
during the course of 2020 and early 2021
when staff here in the prime minister's
own office um
holding gatherings in breach of
coronavirus lockdown rules uh the prime
minister himself was issued with a fixed
penalty fine by the police as a result
of attending one of these gatherings
again he followed a typical pattern of
boris johnson which is first of all to
deny that there was anything going wrong
but then to apologize and say well we
consider the mata closed it won't wash
anymore and now he's out
al jazeera's paul brennan reporting live
there from downing street in london just
to remind you once again british media
are reporting that uh prime minister
boris johnson has agreed to resign he's
faced a growing rebellion within his
ruling party over a series of scandals
number 10 has not said anything other
than the prime minister will make a
statement to the country later today